but we're going to begin this morning
with the Fallout from the deadly beating
of Tyree Nichols over the weekend we saw
mostly peaceful protests Nationwide
after Memphis Police released body cam
video of his arrest five of the officers
involved are now charged with
second-degree murder after they were
fired for others who arrived on the
scene including two firefighters are
also now under investigation now we have
to warn you here we're going to show you
some of this video and it is extremely
difficult and disturbing to watch at
least pressed his at least Preston is in
Memphis with more on the story please
good morning to you so here's a question
how has the community responded after
looking at the footage
well Gail there has been outraged prayer
and protests over the death of 29 year
old Tyree Nichols a father who loved
photography and skateboarding the
question everyone seems to be asking is
how did a traffic stop escalate so
violently
a wave of demonstrations demanding
police reform from Memphis
to Los Angeles
to New York
thank you
like this should never happen to anybody
followed Friday's release of videos
showing the brutal beating of Tyree
Nichols it began as a traffic stop on
January 7th for what officers said was
reckless driving
police pulled nickels from his vehicle
they then pepper spray and attempt to
tase him
before he breaks free and flees police
caught up to him less than 100 yards
from his mother's home
a pool camera shows officers kicking
punching and striking nickels with a
baton while he is being restrained for
roughly three minutes he is then dragged
and propped against a car without first
aid where he struggles to stay upright
it takes at least 20 minutes before an
ambulance arrives Nichols died at the
hospital three days later I could only
look at it one time that's all I needed
in an interview with CBS News the
Memphis police chief said she felt
outraged watching the footage and
questioned the reason for pulling
nickels over this very puzzling for me
that I don't have the information that I
need to at least understand what started
this the five former Memphis police
officers are facing several charges
including second-degree murder
aggravated kidnapping and official
oppression all are out of jail on bond
nichols's family says anyone on the
scene who did not help Tyree should be
charged there were other officers that
you saw and they did nothing to help do
you want those officers to be charged as
well yes I do you saw them all walking
around while my son was on the ground
and no one went to assist him that's a
Daryl election of Duty my son loved me
to death and I loved him to death we
just had a special bond they always say
no parent should ever have to bury a
child what does it feel like to bury
your son after losing him in this way I
have no words for that
I am still trying to wrap my head around
all of this I'm still in disbelief
really
now a lawyer for one of the charged
former officers told CBS News a thorough
investigation of all angles must be done
meanwhile loved ones and civil rights
leaders will say goodbye to Tyree
Nichols at this church here in Memphis
on Wednesday Vlad
you know we are all trying to wrap our
heads around this one Elise in Memphis
thank you very much